entrez entrez et vous devez observer à
des phénomènes les plus mystérieux de
l'univers est ce un homme ou une belle
cette créature a été examiné par les
plus éminents scientifiques qui ont
déclaré sans équivoque qu'il s'agit d'un
homme
je suis prêt à vous offrir mesdames et
messieurs une dernière chance de venir
observer cette curiosité absolument
d'où vient cette créature
engendrés par la même culture et la même
menace qui nous ont tous fait venir sur
ses terres mais quelque chose a mal
tourné dans le ventre maternel
pratiques de vie
[Musique]
est ce une bête
et
oui ça dope
vous avez de la chance car ce soir vous
le verrez se nourrir
[Musique]
ou découvrir
si c'est un homme ou une baird